Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. This will be my full
Star Warsandor episode 12 finale video, there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and references and we know
what's going on with season two so I'll explain
that during the video too if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
episodes there are a bunch a bunch of Star Wars
series that are coming next year the Mandalorian
season 3 will be the first one in February of
course I'll be doing videos for all that stuff
we'll get a new trailer for Mando season three
really soon as well careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll start at the
beginning and work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs WTF moments as we go
along starting with the episode title rix road
which is the name of the main road through
the town on ferrix that they close down for
the mother's funeral the whole idea is that the
Empire is trying to catch them there the rebels
luthen wanted to kill him there the Empire
wanted him alive and you also have Syril Karn
who's still trying to catch him so you have all
these different factions converging on Rix Road
in the episode the actual opening scenes of Dedra
coming to ferrix with her death Troopers you see
big still recovering from her between sessions
in the hotel and his picture there is meant to
be a reminder of why he hates the Empire why
he's doing this they also use maarva's hologram
at the end of the episode her message is this
big rallying cry which is probably one of the
greatest speeches in all of Star Wars now it was
a great scene right here at the beginning when
Brasso starts talking to their friend about Andor
coming back behind them in the shop the ship that
they're working on looks kind of like it's part of
a Pod racer like there are a couple Easter eggs in
the background of some of these shots but it's
really dark so you gotta look really carefully
this seems like a modified R2 unit there's a
bunch of droids repurposed that are like all
over the place there's one that they're working
on in the background in pieces I couldn't quite
tell what kind of droid it is but if you think
you know this one that's in pieces let me know
in the comments when Dedra and the other Imperial
spies start walking around town the funny thing
about this is they look so out of place like the
worst disguises ever you'd immediately know that
they were not part of this town the same is
true when Syril Karn also shows up here too
with the sergeant it was completely out of place
completely different from all the other locals we
find out that nirchi the loan shark that Andor
owed money to at the beginning of the series is
basically trying to find out where he is and rat
him out to earn more money like a finder's fee
he winds up getting his comeuppance by the end
of the episode too serves him right for trying
to rat out Andor 99 of the finale is focused
on what's happening with Andor the Empire on
ferrix but they do have a couple scenes with
Mod mothma when mod mothma gets pissed off at
her husband for gambling supposedly obviously this
is meant to be a cover for what's happening with
Davos golden and the funds that she's borrowing
illicitly from him but it's not totally clear if
her husband is actually in on this ruse too like
she knows that there's an Imperial spy working
for the ISB listening to them and she's putting
on this act acting like she's pissed off at her
husband for gambling again but I couldn't tell
if her husband is completely oblivious to this
because he's also totally oblivious to the ISB
spy if it wasn't clear this season mon mothma
has been keeping him on the dark about everything
that she's been doing he also isn't aware of the
deal that she made with Davos golden we do get a
couple answers about her storyline like dedra's
old Nemesis of the ISB blevin winds up being
the one behind the Spy who's been keeping tabs
on her and they plan to use the knowledge about
the gambling debts against her to either ensure
her loyalty so that she doesn't continue working
against the empire within the senate or they can
just use it as an excuse to kill her and get rid
of any problems that she might cause them in the
future obviously kind of a moot point because
we know what happens to mod mothma she winds up
joining the Rebellion the emperor dissolves the
Senate just before the events of A New Hope but
at the end of the episode when Davos golden shows
up with his family his son to meet her daughter it
just confirms that she said yes to his deal so it
was a little disappointed that they didn't pay off
as much of her storyline like I said previously
I think heading into season two they'll just use
luthen's funds to solve all of her problems but
it's also kind of a moot point because even if
the empire did find out the emperor is going to
dissolve the Senate within a couple years anyway
what I was really looking for was her husband and
her daughter winding up killed because we don't
see them anywhere during the original trilogy and
it seems like Leia Becomes Her surrogate daughter
probably because something terrible happens
to her real daughter velsartha reunites with
Sinta and it seems like she's cracking under the
pressure like Sinta is core Rebellion she's all
about the mission but it seems like Val sartha
is wavering just under all the stress you also
get the vibe later when she reunites with luthen
that he's ready to kill Andor throw him under the
bus to protect the secret of the Rebellion even
though he's inspired to bring him in by the end
of the episode don't worry I'll talk about that
too because it was also a great scene but early
in the episode when he's still planning on killing
him velstartha just seems like she really hates
the idea when Andor sneaks back into town he's
in the same area in rix road the main road that
they're in the big fight later in the episode
behind him it also seems that there's another
repurposed R5 Droid the arabesh writing itched
into the Brick in the Wall which seems precious
to him is his father because we see the flashback
to his father in The Brick has the same writing on
it that his mother's brick has on it remember the
whole custom with their people is that they bake
the ashes of the deceased into these bricks and
then use the bricks to build structures around
the town so literally his father is buried here
in this wall also his father was killed by the
Empire on rix road if it wasn't clear the riot at
the end of the episode was meant to be a parallel
for the riot that killed his father earlier in
his life when he has the flashback to his father
teaching him about repurposing old Tech like look
at all this old valuable stuff that people don't
care about they're ready to sell it to you for
500 credits it's worth so much money it's also
meant to be a parallel for maarva's speech at the
end of the episode when she talks about rising
up people being asleep not really caring about
things anymore like they should have been time
to take care of business get rid of the Empire a
lot of it's all in metaphors but all the speeches
like his speech in the flashback in Her speech is
more literally meant to be anti-empire everybody
rise up join the Rebellion basically they have
another scene of nemix's voice over reading his
Manifesto as he's actually reading the book
that he gave him earlier that's meant to be a
Manifesto of the Rebellion itself like a treaty
that he wrote about the actual Rebellion why it
exists it just meant to flow with the idea that
he's coming around on the idea of the Rebellion
just in general like he's starting to actually
care what's going on care about getting rid of
the Empire whereas previously he was shown to be
a very selfish person he really only cared about
finding his sister which they never answered
during this episode I was a little upset about
that I'll address that later in the video but also
he'd only want to earn enough credit so that he
and Maarva could Escape somewhere in the Galaxy
where they wouldn't be bothered by the Empire
but the whole joke of that as Maarva said is that
the Empire's everywhere you can't go anywhere to
escape them no matter where you go they will find
you which they paid off earlier on the show kind
of hilariously in a Twist when he's just walking
around and gets thrown in prison for doing nothing
they reference the daughters of ferrix again
claiming that they're a social club on the surface
but really it's a revolutionary group that's
been around on the planet for a long time not
officially Rebellion but their own sort of small
anti-empire resistance cell made up of all the
people in the town which they referenced in last
week's episode when Brasso was talking to B2 emo
the daughters of ferrix need your help on a matter
of great importance now we know what the matter of
great importance was it was all about the Hologram
that he was holding that he emitted with maarva's
speech inspired them all to rebel against the
empire we also learned that andor's mother used to
be the president of that organization back at the
ISB we learned what happened with their mission to
take down Anto Kreegyr's group they claimed they
were all killed no survivors it happened super
quickly which is good for luthen because no one
was alive to inform on him Dedra is pissed for
the exact same reason like she wanted someone
alive so they could question them which is why
they want andor alive pardagas claims the reason
why they didn't take any prisoners is because they
wanted to send a message from Emperor Palpatine
to the rest of the Galaxy to not rebel against
the empire it's about sending a message partagas
claims finding luthin even though they still don't
know that it's luthen they're just calling him
axis is the only way to keep her Mission alive in
the ISB about the Rebellion otherwise they'll just
assign her to different duties the funny thing is
like most of the other ISB officers here aren't
really that worried about the Rebellion they
think that they just crushed it when they killed
Anton Krieger's Group which was luthen's whole
plan like he was using Anto Kreegyr is the Patsy
so that a lot of the heat on him would go away
giving him the time to build the traditional rebel
base on Yavin 4 and like the larger Rebellion to
actually come together because they still have
those 80 million credits they stole so they got
a whole lot of ships a whole lot of weapons to buy
luthan then arrives on farrix because he's there
to kill andor obviously things go a slightly
different way because he's also inspired by
maarva's speech and when he sees what's happened
with Andor and how he's come around he sees an
opportunity like either kill me or bring me in
and he chooses to bring him in just bringing him
into the traditional Rebellion not to the Empire
like ah you've reached your lowest point you have
nothing left to live for now it's time for you to
join the Rebellion when Andor reunites with Brasso
who gives him his mother's last message to him is
basically a metaphor for him joining the Rebellion
like it's all about the spark starting the fire
which is a metaphor for the spark of the Rebellion
she was basically telling him that she always knew
that eventually he would come around eventually he
would stop being a selfish person start caring
about what's happening with the Empire and do
something about it see comes back to town love
the moment with him and the sergeant like this
is like this funny pair of the two of them like
total Bros total mates from back in the day even
though at the end of the episode they sort of end
things with the sergeant sitting there by himself
in the street just kind of chilling out after the
riot I think the idea is that he continues into
season two working with Syril Karn but at this
moment he's just waiting for Syril Karn to come
back with deadra the reason why the daughters
of ferrix start the funeral procession early
is to throw off the Empire because they thought
it was coming later so they want to catch them
unawares and all the different factions in the
episode like the Empire seal akarn luthin the
rebels all converge on Rix Road it was a great
scene like this big funeral procession one of
the other Hilarious Moments early on here too is
as they're all assembling in the Town Square you
see Syril Karn walk right by luthen the person he
was chasing much earlier in the series the person
who is much more important than Andor it just
meant to show you one of the great Follies of
the character that he's so focused on Andor that
he's missing the big picture luthin the axis of
all Rebel activity in the gala galaxy is the big
picture don't tell Dedra what's going on because
she'd be pissed off if she knew about this you
walked right by him and you did nothing and like
I said her speech in the episode probably one
of the all-time great Star Wars speeches now
it was an awesome scene we find out how Andor
got his name Cassian Andor from his mother is
his mother's name basically Maarva Cassia Andor
his real birth name is still Casa like I said
they'd never answered what happened with his
sister this season like earlier in the season
the last we heard of it his mother was telling
him ah forget about that forget about finding
your sister and that's it clearly that's not it
I'm assuming now that they just pushed that into
season two and at some point he will find out what
really happened with his sister so Theory crafting
still wide open for that what actually did wind up
happening to his sister will he find her before he
dies during Rogue one or has he already found her
and just doesn't realize that he's found her when
she talks about being worthy of the stone she's
talking about the actual physical stone that they
use with her ashes we learned ferrix had been
her home her entire life she she had a sister
who lived there with her when they were younger it
also helps explain why she didn't leave with Andor
when he asked her to because it was the only home
that she'd ever known her entire speech is meant
to be a memorial but also inspiration to the rest
of the citizens here the daughters of ferrix as
well as Andor himself to rebel against the empire
continue resisting the Empire the whole metaphor
about them having been sleeping is all about andor
the others ignoring the threat of the empire for
too long which he also refers to as the darkness
reaching into everything around the Galaxy like
rust in the speech also winds up inspiring luthen
even though he's already been hardcore Rebellion
this whole time it just reminds him of why he's
been doing all these things they set off the
homemade bomb which starts the riot which causes
a bunch of collateral damage killing a bunch of
other Imperials because their grenades go off
too so it's like them taking out 20 Imperials
and a bunch of their equipment for the price of
one he even winds up taking out that traitorous
former friend who tried to sell andor out Sinta
takes out that Imperial spy she'd been clocking
for the last several weeks working for deadra
zero car and rest excuse Dedra predictably after
she almost gets taken out by the mob during the
riot Lord of simps continues to simp his way into
season two probably gaining himself a promotion
to the ISB like he originally wanted would not be
surprised if he's actually working with Dedra more
formally during season two if we're making jokes
about Kinks those two characters just having
weird Kings the funny thing about Dedra is
that she has a praise Kink and that's all Syril
Karn has been doing is simping her praising her
left and right and it just seems like he would
do anything to become her more formal Whipping
Boy make all the jokes that you want about the two
of them andor winds up rescuing Bix bringing her
to the ship that Brasso and a few of the others
are using to escape the planet including B2 emo
they said they're going directly to the ganji
Moon nearby But ultimately I think the idea is
that anyone who survives here past this point
is joining the Rebellion it'll wind up on Yavin
for at their base when they set up the larger
Rebellion during season 2 which is basically
what he's talking about when Bix is saying he'll
find us again we'll meet again he will meet them
again probably at yavan 4 they have that great
ending scene too with Andor surprising luthen
back at a ship trying to sacrifice himself like
I said the reason why he did that is because he
lost everything like he had nothing left to
live for so when he surprised him there he
wasn't thinking about joining the Rebellion he
wasn't trying to ask luthen to bring him in he
was saying to him that he's tired of running
so either kill me or take me into the Empire
but luthen is thinking no no I'll bring you in
to the actual rebellion and speaking of luthen
there was a big Easter egg that they clarified
in a previous episode so earlier on the show he
had this mystery weapon that people thought might
have been a lightsaber or a Jedi Temple Guardian
staff they thought that luthen might be a former
Jedi or a former Jedi Temple Guardian the reason
why I didn't talk about this is because I didn't
think that he had a lightsaber I didn't think that
he used to be a Jedi or anything like that in the
Star Wars people clarified that that actually is
correct and his weapon was actually just a plain
old knife like nothing that special but surprise
maybe not surprised there is a post-credits scene
they reveal what Andor and the prisoners were
building and it confirms a bunch of everyone's
theory he's like it was very common theory that
they were building parts for the Death Star they
were making them build the thing that they would
eventually wind up using against them except it
goes even further than that because the parts
that they were building were specifically for
the dish of the super laser so very literally
Andor was building the very thing that would
wind up killing him during Rogue one it'd be
like forcing a prisoner to build a gun than
picking the gun up and shooting him with it
but the big plans for season 2 is that the story
is going to change a little bit because they're
going to be time jumps during each new arc each
three episodes there's like a new arc in the show
during season two they're gonna jump through time
way faster because season one takes place mostly
about five years before Rogue one and season two
we'll cover the rest of the remaining years to the
beginning of Rogue one so over season two we'll
see the formal Rebellion form on Yavin 4 like the
larger fighting force with all their ships all
their weapons the emperor dissolving the Senate
mon mothma fully joining the Rebellion they start
filming this month they probably won't be able to
get all the episodes out in time for next year
there'll be 12 episodes in season two just like
season one season two probably going to Premiere
early 2024 after the New Republic show the Star
Wars acolyte series is meant to be the new Sith
show that they're doing set about a hundred years
ago maybe we'll see some Darth Plagueis the Wise
have I ever told you the tragedy of Darth Plagueis
the Wise Darth Plagueis was actually the reason
why Palpatine became the Imperial senator from
Naboo he made that possible Palpatine's plan to
take over the Galaxy was originally Darth Plagueis
plan issues that at a certain point Palpatine
killed his master to become the Sith Master
because that's usually what happens there's always
two in The Apprentice usually winds up killing
the master to become the master but because of
the events of season 2 in the formation of the
Rebellion we might get an Ahsoka Cameo because she
was the fulcrum character like she was responsible
for the formation of the Rebellion she served as
the point of communications between all the rebel
cells she was a really important person during
the Rebellion maybe a Princess Leia Cameo maybe
some of the live-action Rebels characters were
also seen during the Ahsoka series like Hera
they deal a lot with the formations of rebellion
during that series of as well and because of the
Death Star we're talking about the Rogue one
characters maybe an Orson Krennic Cameo Galen
Erso still alive working on the Death Star right
now so maybe Mads Mikkelsen will also be on the
series also maybe a Jyn Erso cameo and k2so any of
the Rogue one characters are fair game for a cameo
during season two maybe maybe outside chance and
Emperor Palpatine Cameo scene in the way that we
saw him briefly Cameo during the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series but if you spotted any other easter eggs
or references during the finale that I didn't
talk about in the video just write them Below in
the comments or if you have big questions about
what's happening in season two like I said the
Mandalorian season 3 trailer will probably drop
relatively soon those episodes are going to start
in February so of course I'll be doing videos for
those just like I did for the previous Seasons as
well the Ahsoka episodes will come sometime after
that probably early summer and I think their
plan right now is to have the Star Wars acolyte
episodes come out at the end of next year everyone
click here for the Mandalorian season 3 trailer
and click here for the Star Wars acolyte teaser
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!